[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another installment old
versus new
what most of these I like to compare
certain elements like best character
best villain and so forth
this episode is going to be more of a
general comparison because this one is
one of teen titans based on the
constantly canceled done canceled
comic-book series Teen Titans found some
of its biggest popularity in 2003 on
Cartoon Network it's dark batman stoic
sidekick Robin leading a team of super
teens to fight evil on a weekly basis
these teens included a moody and paths
from a parallel universe named Raven a
half human half robot football player
named cyborg a curious energy zapping
alien named Starfire and the literal
party animal who can change into any
creature he wants Beast Boy they reside
in their headquarters a phenomenally
unsubtle t outside of Metropolis and
protect this city from all sorts of
villains like the Brotherhood of Evil
mumbo and their biggest threat
Slade the best way I can describe the
show is it's kinda like a mix between
Avatar The Last Airbender and Batman the
Animated Series so as you'd imagine it
had a pretty diehard following it had a
lot of action and a lot of superpowers
but it also took time to flesh out their
characters and focus on the dramatic
wait each person is carrying that's not
to say it couldn't be phenomenally goofy
though - unlike other DC animations Teen
Titans had a heavy anime influence when
it came to their comedy often distorting
their line work in unsolved extremes
changing sizes and screaming while
colored lines flew behind them and just
being very anime it was an acquired
taste to say the least as this comedy
was used a lot but his fan base got into
the way it smoothly transition from
over-the-top comedy to well-written
drama lasting an impressive five seasons
on Cartoon Network and wrapping up with
a TV movie finale ten years after the
premiere of the original show Cartoon
Network announced that Teen Titans were
coming back and in all new series called
Teen Titans go fans were ecstatic that
is a lie well at least among the
original fans new fans primarily young
kids we're absolutely thrilled Teen
Titans go start the exact same
characters in the exact same plot but
its tone and style were 100 percent
different this was silly immature
childish and relished every second of it
where the original show sprinkle did say
any comedy among the attends drama this
was nothing but the zany comedy feeling
closer to Spongebob rather than the
original teen tie
where the original might deal with
Starfire's feelings of isolation or
Ravens relationship with their demonic
father this one focused on waffles yeah
that was a bit they constantly broke the
fourth wall combined industry jokes with
fart jokes and kids seemed to laugh
their heads off in it so much so that
they even got a cinematic release and
the God surprisingly good reviews with
many critics saying it was not only
funny but they may actually go and watch
the show based on how much they enjoyed
it so it seems even adults can get into
the wacky childish humor but the hatred
this show received from the fans of the
original is I don't know if I want to
use the words impressive or scary so
I'll just say impressively scary so many
say this is a betrayal of what the
original show was and constantly draw
attention to how insulting ly inferior
it is to the original fear not DC's
totally fixing this problem as we speak
I've seen both series enough times to
get an idea of what they're about what
the characters are like and what both
show strengths and weaknesses are be
honest I feel like I'm the right type of
person to compare and contrast these two
because I don't really love either of
them I know there's a lot to them Teen
Titans is beautifully animated written
and acted it's just not a show that ever
grabbed me like Batman or avatar Teen
Titans go is very energized fast and
uses creatively wild humor it just
doesn't tickle me though like say Ren
and Stimpy or Looney Tunes so I feel
like I can look at both of these shows
and partially judging them on what they
are and not what I want them to be
because of the nature of the shows being
so drastically different it doesn't make
sense for me to do element by element
comparisons like the other old versus
news it's like comparing Adam West to
Michael Keaton there's such different
genres it doesn't really make sense this
is more a comparison of how well each
show makes its impact if they change the
genre they're in in any way and how
watchable they'll be years from now with
that said what do these shows do that
caught on with so many people well aside
from being a dramatic and emotionally
driven show like many other DC
properties at the time Teen Titans was
one of the first dramatic cartoons to
incorporate a sharp style change when it
came to its sense of humor as mentioned
before this is something that will be
done often in anime and even in the show
avatar so well that people even confuse
avatar for an
what makes team titans so unique though
is that law it's clearly anime inspired
it's still Warner Brothers animation so
it looks a little more like Animaniacs
half the time combining several
different types of comedic visual styles
that as far as I know has never really
been replicated like this the reason
this is so important is that the
audience can laugh harder and thus we
like these characters more so we feel
for them when they have to go through
the tough emotional journey since then a
lot of other shows have used this
over-the-top comedy to blend with their
action but Teen Titans was one of the
first if not the first American show to
implement it with such tireless
consistency Batman could be funny but it
was still primarily serious Hey Arnold
could be serious I was still primarily
funny Teen Titans was a total 50-50
split where the mixing of extreme drama
and extreme silliness are very common
now in modern kid shows Teen Titans was
one of the originators to go super
ridiculous in one moment and then super
depressing in another and they somehow
still fit in the environment and tone of
the episode while everything else about
it is done very very well this is one of
the main elements that separates it from
other shows Teen Titans go as said
before just go solely for the labs but
is there anything really different it's
doing for comedy or animation well the
designs are colorful and energized
they're really nothing new compared to
other shows on TV currently nor is the
zany style of humor as we've seen that a
lot of other shows too there is however
one element that separates it from other
shows of its kind its self-aware of
self-abuse the writers are aware of the
backlash many fans have and they
constantly work it into the show don't
get me wrong many shows and movies have
attacked their viewers before some
successfully there's that please please
PLEASE getalife foundation some not so
successfully there is no originality
left in the world
mr. Heath a Teen Titans go constantly
comes up with different ways as well as
attitudes in addressing the hate they
get sometimes they go after the fans
you're too old for clowns
oh it's way cooler this clown is for
kids yes
clowns are for kids sometimes they go
after themselves do you like the Teen
Titans or the Teen Titans
make sense I mean animation wise is
really no comparison sometimes they even
just celebrate the fans they have
there's one episode where they write in
a real kid from the make-a-wish
Foundation and not only poked fun of the
fact that somebody actually really likes
them but also dedicates a song to him at
the end even flying him out for the
recording of the episode I think you
found a fan base is something that can
easily backfire and Teen Titans go only
did one way of poking fun of the fan
base say bitterly insulting them only it
probably wouldn't have worked but
because they mix it up every time one
minute praising themselves another
minute crapping on themselves
I thought everyone considered us an
abomination they do and sometimes
combining so much you're not even sure
if they're making commentary or just
telling the jokes needed for the story
it cleverly plays many sides the same
can be said for at shots at DC the movie
was especially harsh on a lot of DC
films shows and comics even make fun of
how overly serious a lot of the DC
properties are becoming to a point where
they're almost not even recognizable I
said before this kind of humor has been
done in many other shows but to do it so
constantly with the company and people
that allow you to do so and in so many
different ways it really is kind of
unique I don't know if it's something
that'll last for years of anything you
could argue it kind of dates it that's
something that certainly makes it stand
out now how about what actually happens
on the shows though the stories the
conflicts etc the original did a pretty
good job of combining episodic
adventures with long-running stories
sometimes it was just a villain of the
week but other times it was an ongoing
battle with a villain that would evolve
along with the Titans and thus give them
new challenges mumbo usually has a new
creative way to try and take the mouth
that usually wraps up at the end of the
episode but other villains learn so much
about the Titans that they can leave
them both figuratively and literally
torn apart a villain named Kotaro beats
Robin so bad that he leaves the Titans
to go figure out more about himself so
he can become stronger both physically
and mentally
Ravens father finds such effective ways
to tighten his grip that it consumes her
almost to her end and of course the
run-ins with Slade that always pose new
chan
just above the willpower and their
weaknesses usually leaves them slightly
if not majorly different people it has
many episodes you can watch by itself
but rewards you if you've watched for a
long time and you can see them grow as
characters Teen Titans go again is
episodic madness but the challenges are
also very enjoyable because well they're
usually very selfish true they do save
the city from various threats but it's
usually for the reason of just wanting
to be famous when that wasting time with
things like waffles they especially
Robin focus on how they can be the most
popular superheroes around the movie
especially focuses on this by trying to
go back in time and stop all the
superheroes origins only to find they
apparently suck so bad as heroes that
the world is on fire and they couldn't
save the day so they put all their
origins back to normal because that does
make me appreciate the challenges
because for children's programming
they're all kind of awful and they know
it and love it it's a kind of balls eNOS
I have to appreciate on some level so
again for what both genres and
demographics they're appealing to they
seem to do a pretty good job but ok
let's get to the tipping point the one
reason that one of these shows is better
than the other that's right there's one
specific reason despite their different
genres that actually makes one far
superior can you guess which one is the
winner at the end of the day of course
it's that one yeah big surprise Teen
Titans is obviously the better show even
though Teen Titans go is an entirely
different genre but what's the ultimate
reason for this choice these characters
were designed for this show these
characters were not you see these
characters were made to work off of each
other more than just comedic Lee they
were supportive of each other angry with
each other in love with each other their
unique personalities were so different
that they could utilize them in both
fighting enemies and their own inner
struggles they were a dynamic that added
both conflict and togetherness with
their personalities alone suddenly you
have to take those same characters and
throw them in a self-absorbed world of
absurdity which can work maybe for an
episode because you're seeing them as
the exact opposite but it's trickier
when he had to have that last for a
series because they weren't originally
designed for a strictly comedic dynamic
you can't expect them to fully thrive as
a comedic team The Three Stooges work as
a comedy team because that's what
they're designed for if they were
suddenly thrown into an action series
that wouldn't make any sense okay it'd
be cool for a minute but it would wear
off very quickly also these characters
suffer from a very similar problem the
new Ninja Turtles suffer from that being
once again they're all essentially the
same character look at this episode
where they need to take down a clown
Raven is in a clown outfit in the
original Teen Titans that would be funny
because it'd be so out of character even
wearing a dress puts her in a bad mood
so wearing a goofy clown outfit should
be hysterical but it's not because she's
already a clown they all are in the same
episode Starfire is afraid of clowns
this is a quality you could give to any
of them and it would make no difference
it would be the same reactions the same
lines the same impact if it was Beast
Boy the reaction would be the same if it
was cyborg the reaction would be the
same even in Looney Tunes the
personalities of Bugs Bunny Daffy Duck
and Elmer Fudd are so different that all
you have to do is put them together and
the comedy writes itself here if there's
too many times where they're all idiots
all blood hungry all party animals their
differences are beyond minor for example
Raven will usually have a frown these
boy will have a smile and Starfire will
save thee a lot they even referenced
that in an episode aside from that
though they usually just all act the
same way even though the voice acting
and the deliveries are still great when
the comedy works
it's 100% what's being said not who said
it
so yes the original Teen Titans is much
better than Teen Titans go it's probably
gonna last years and years and years but
it's still kind of fascinating the hey
Teen Titans go gets don't get me wrong I
can see why some people don't like the
show and I myself amazing Teen Titan go
jokes before but the outrage some fans
have over it does make me wonder if it's
not only worth it but possibly fueling
it I always see people post how bad the
show is and the latest atrocity that
happened in the latest episode but if
you don't like it why are you watching
it how do you know about these
atrocities the clueless attention you
can give any form of entertainment is no
attention if people don't watch it they
don't pay
get so why do so many haters watch it
especially if it's clearly intended for
younger kids we got excited going from
the 60s Batman to the Tim Burton Batman
in fact if anything it seemed really
cool to go to something so different but
at the same time we did go from the Tim
Burton Batman to the Joel Schumacher
Batman and that was not as cool
especially because it was the same
actors doing a more silly style that
none of us wanted it's hard not to see a
comparison but those movies had little
in terms of being clever and even though
Teen Titans go can get a little annoying
sometimes it does have its clever
moments maybe it's also because the
original show was canceled and nobody
really knows the reason why so they have
a new show replace it that not only
portrays them as goofy characters but
also seems to be popular enough to get
its own theatrical movie and the other
one just getting a TV movie
perhaps Teen Titans go just happened too
soon I mean it wasn't that many years
since the last one stopped I don't know
if I would be ready for something so
different so close to when the original
aired whatever the reason it still has a
fanbase of both kids and surprisingly
adults DC has teased new versions of
Teen Titans in the near future maybe
even a return to the original whatever
is in store for them there is no doubt
that Teen Titans is a unique and
powerful show that will last for years
Teen Titans go it's a waste a time that
brings joy to a lot of kids and even
some adults and both are totally fine
for doing so no matter what your
thoughts are on Teen Titans or Teen
Titans go they definitely both left a
big impact pleased a lot of people
angered a lot of people confused a lot
of people either way we watched and
maybe the power of these characters is
no matter what scenario they're put in
genre style or whatever they'll always
last in one way or another because there
will always be a uniqueness that draws
us to them
you know and for all the talk of how bad
Teen Titans go I was really let down I
want to see something amazingly bad like
shockingly bad you hear me universe that
just keeps giving me bad movies to watch
I want something so bad I can't believe
it a new kind of bad that'll blow me
away
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing
finca international individuals living
in the world's most challenging
economies live without access to
critical financial tools these tools
enable progress towards healthier more
resilient lives
finca International was founded in 1984
on the notion that giving small loans to
the poor has the power to transform
entire communities in sustainable ways
after impacting tens of millions of lies
with responsible financial services they
are widening their focus to catalyze
further economic growth in underserved
markets around the world they remain
committed to market-based solutions and
are supporting the rise of social
enterprises developing basic service and
financial innovation to help low-income
families and communities achieve a
better standard of living if you look at
their site in their YouTube channel you
can see how much stability they bring
across Africa Eurasia Latin America the
Middle East and South Asia and with an A
rating on charity watch it's hard not to
be impressed click on the link and help
these people who have over 30 years
experience transforming lives reshaping
poverty and strengthening communities
[Music]
you